تصرح إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) بالاستخدام
الطارئ لاختبار مستضد أبوت السريع الذي
يمكن أن يعطي نتائج في دقائق. سيكلف ذلك
خمسة دولارات ، إنه يقارب
حجم بطاقة الائتمان.
أريكم بعض البيانات المتعلقة
بهذا الأمر وقد كنا نتابع القصة
لبعض الوقت كما أشرت إلى
أنه اختبار بخمسة دولارات
سريع جدًا 15 دقيقة آه 97
حساسية هذا أمر جيد حقًا
تعرفون أن هذه الأرقام أعني ثلاثة من أصل
100  سيتم إخبار الأشخاص بأن لديهم
اختبارًا سلبيًا عندما لا يكون
ذلك في الأشخاص الذين يتم
اختبارهم في غضون سبعة أيام من
ظهور أعراضهم ،
وهذا هو المفتاح الذي لا يتطلب أي معدات ،
ولا تحتاج إلى إرسال هذا إلى
المختبر  لا توجد آلة يجب
أن تمتلكها ، إنها مجرد مجموعة الاختبار وأنت
في نفس المكان الذي تجري فيه الاختبار
يمكنك الحصول على نتيجة ، وهم في
هذه
الشركة الكبيرة في أبوت يمكنهم إجراء 50 مليون من
هذه الاختبارات شهريًا بواسطة oc
أنا وتوبر يمكنني تأكيد جيك ، لقد تحدثت للتو إلى
الأدميرال جيرارد حول هذا
الأمر ، سيعلنون
أنهم سيشترون 150 مليونًا من هذه الاختبارات
مقابل 750 مليون دولار
وسيحصلون على هذا المبلغ بحلول نهاية نوفمبر
من الاختبارات التي تم شراؤها بالفعل ،
دعني أوضح لك
سريعًا أن لدينا بعض الفيديوهات التي أريد
أن أوضح لك كيف تعمل لأن هذا
مثير للاهتمام حقًا ،
فأنت تعلم أن الأشخاص على
دراية بجزء المسحة من هؤلاء
الأشخاص  في الواقع ، بعد إجراء الاختبار ،
يمكننا عرض هذا
الفيديو وهو عبارة عن مجموعة بطاقات ائتمان صغيرة ،
يجب عليك مسح رمز الاستجابة السريعة الخاص بك
والذي يربط بشكل أساسي هذه
المجموعة بالفرد
الذي تقوم بإجراء المسحة كما تعلم أن
الأشخاص قد رأوا مرات لا تحصى
ولكن هنا المكان  إنه مختلف قليلاً
مرة أخرى ، كل شيء مكتفي ذاتيًا
قليلًا من السوائل على تلك الورقة
يطلق عليه تقنية التدفق الجانبي والتي
تسمح للسائل
بالتسلل عبر الورقة
التي تشبكها لأسفل.  في غضون
15 دقيقة مثل اختبار الحمل ، يتم
إخبارك بشكل أساسي إذا كنت
إيجابيًا أو سلبيًا ،
يحصل شخص ما على تطبيق على
هاتفه ويقال له إنك حصلت على اللون الأخضر وهذا يعني
أنك سلبي
ويتصرف مثل القليل من
جواز سفر هكذا ستعمل هذه الاختبارات
ويبدو
جيك واعدًا جدًا إذا كان بإمكانهم الحصول على هذه
الأرقام
حتى النقطة التي يقولون إنهم يستطيعون